♪
>> [INAUDIBLE]
PETE: NEW LEAKED VIDEO SHOWING A
TENSE CONFRONTATION BETWEEN
BORDER PATROL AGENTS AND THEIR
CHIEF DURING DHS SECRETARY
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS' VISIT TO
LAREDO, TEXAS.
THIS COMES AS KAMALA HARRIS
ADMITS IT'S GOING TO TAKE A,
QUOTE, LONG PERIOD OF TIME TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
>> THE WORK WE NEED TO DO IS
GOING TO BE WORK THAT MANIFESTS
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
HOPEFULLY NOT TOO LONG, BUT
CERTAINLY NOT OVERNIGHT.
PETE: OUR NEXT GUEST JUST
RETURNED PROSECUTE BORDER WHERE
HE LEARNED ABOUT ILLEGALS --
FROM ILLEGALS AND MIGRANTS ABOUT
THE DANGERS CARTELS ARE
PRESENTING.
U.S. SENATE CANDIDATE FOR OHIO
BERNIE MORENO JOINS US NOW.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE, THANKS
FOR MAKING THE TRIP.
IF YOU WOULD, YOU'VE GOT BORDER
PATROL AGENTS IN REVOLT BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DO THEIR
JOB.
YOU'VE GOT KAMALA HARRIS SAYING
IT'S ALL ABOUT ROOT CAUSES, BUT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A WHILE.
WHEN YOU'RE DOWN THERE, WHAT DO
YOU SEE IN -- SEE?
>> WELL, SHE'S EXACTLY WRONG.
YOU CAN'T SOLVE A PROBLEM BY
IGNORING IT.
SHE'S NEVER EVEN BEEN THERE.
BORDER PATROL AGENTS AREN'T
ASKING FOR MORE RESOURCES OR
MORE PEOPLE.
WHAT THEY WANT IS GOOD POLICY.
AND THESE POLICIES CAN HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT.
WE CAN FIX THE PROBLEM.
BUT SHE'S YOUR TYPICAL
POLITICIAN THAT WON'T GO DOWN
THERE AND ACTUALLY TALK TO THE
FRONT-LINE PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY I WENT DOWN THERE.
THESE THINGS CAN BE FIXED, PETE.
WE NEED TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY,
AND WE NEED TO INSIST THAT
LEADERS DEFEND US AND KEEP US
SAFE.
PETE: WELL, I'M TOLD WHAT YOU
SAW DOWN THERE WAS HARROWING.
CARTELS, RAPES, YOU KNOW,
WHAT -- OR AT LEAST WORD OF
THOSE THINGS.
WHAT DID YOU SEE AS FAR AS RIGHT
NOW ON THE BORDER WHAT THE
CARTELS ARE DOING?
>> WELL, WHAT WE'RE, WHAT THE
POLICIES OF JOE BIDEN ARE DOING
IS ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING TO
THESE MIGRANTS.
THEY GO THROUGH A TERRIBLE
JOURNEY.
THE WOMEN ARE RAPED.
12-YEAR-OLD GIRLS ARE FORCED TO
TAKE BIRTH CONTROL BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE RAPED
ALONG THE JOURNEY.
WOMEN WE MET HAD BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED, MEN BEATEN AND HELD
AT GUNPOINT.
THEY GOT CHARGED A RIVER TAX FOR
CROSSING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THAT KIND OF
DESTRUCTION OF HUMANITY TO OCCUR
BECAUSE OF OUR BAD POLICIES.
AND, AGAIN, THESE THINGS CAN BE
FIXED.
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED.
IT'S COMMON SENSE.
PETE: THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT'S WHY WHAT KAMALA HARRIS
SAID HAS BEEN A SHAM FROM THE
BEGINNING, IT'S A SHAM TODAY.
WHAT I RESPECT A LOT MORE ARE
THE GUYS AND GALS ON THE BORDER
ACTUALLY DOING THE JOB.
YOU SAW THAT REVOLT TO THE
BORDER CHIEF THERE.
IS THAT IN KEEPING FROM WHAT YOU
HEARD AS WELL, THAT AGENTS ARE
CHOMPING TO DO THEIR JOB, IT'S
JUST -- IT IS, WE KNOW THE
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP IS FAILING
THEM.
THE LEADERSHIP -- IS THE
LEADERSHIP AT THE TOP OF THE
BORDER PATROL COMPLICIT BECAUSE
THEY'RE WILLING TO GO ALONG WITH
POLICIES THAT DON'T WORK?
>> I THINK THEY'VE IN A TOUGH
SITUATION BECAUSE THE POLICIES
COME RIGHT OUT OF WASHINGTON,
D.C..
THIS IS INTENTIONAL.
WE'RE USING THESE MIGRANTS AS
POLITICAL PAWNS TO CREATE WHAT
THEY WANT, WHICH IS A DIFFERENT
VOTER, A DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHIC
IN AMERICA.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS THAT WE
MET WITH HAD CAPTURED ONE PERSON
WITH ENOUGH FENTANYL ON HIM TO
KILL 450,000 PEOPLE.
JUST ONE.
PETE: WOW.
>> OUT OF WHAT HE ESTIMATES IS A
MILLION WHO GOT AWAY.
SO MILLIONS THAT GOT AWAY.
OUR COUNTRY IS IN GRAVE DANGER.
WE'RE BEING INVADED AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, AND JOE BIDEN'S
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE UKRAINE
BORDER THAN OUR OWN BORDER.
WE HAVE TO MAKE THIS A TOP
PRIORITY.
OF --
PETE: AMEN.
IF WE DON'T HAVE A BORDER, WE
DON'T HAVE A COUNTRY, AS DONALD
TRUMP TALKED ABOUT.
AND RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE ONE,
YET WE'RE OBSESSED WITH ONE
HALFWAY AROUND THE WORLD.
BERNIE MORENO, RUNNING FOR
SENATE IN OHIO.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AND
GOING DOWN TO